also das heutige gehört haben breaking
news Habeck entlässt reichen doch wann
haben Sie davon erfahren
ich habe schon ein bisschen früher davon
gewusst und ich bin der Meinung ist ein
richtig entscheiden die da getroffen
wurde
Patrick greifen ich glaube das ist jetzt
entscheidende Frage von die
entscheidende Frage ist was am Ende
passiert Patrick reichen hat sich im
letzten Jahr sehr verdient um dieses
Land gemacht wenn es darum ging eine
Wirtschaftskrise abzuwenden wenn es
darum ging warum wir alle großen die
garspeicher zu füllen aber am Ende wurde
eine Entscheidung getroffen das ist eine
Gesamtschau nicht mehr funktioniert und
ich habe vor allem gedacht jetzt ist
doch der Moment nach vorne zu schauen
also nochmal die Frage wann haben Sie
davon erfahren gehörten sie zu der
Gruppe die das mit entschieden hat oder
wurde das im kleinen Kreis entschieden
die Entscheidung wurde zwischen Robert
habe und Patrick reichen getroffen
seit sie waren nicht involviert nein das
ist auch eine entscheidende Ministerium
gehört aus meiner Sicht das heißt die
Grünen Spitze war nicht involviert in
dieser Entscheidung es geht hier um
Staatssekretär und wie gesagt einen der
sich sehr verdienten dieses Land gemacht
hat wofür ich dankbar bin aber es geht
auch darum am Ende zu sagen in der
Gesamtschau war es ein Fehler zu viel
und es hat geht es jetzt nicht mehr
weiter und ich finde es ist eine
richtige Entscheidung ich finde vor
allem ist an dieser Stelle eine
konsequente Entscheidung von Robert
Habeck konsequent ja also diese
Entscheidung war alles mögliche aber
konsequent und schnell war das nicht ich
glaube das ist ein bisschen eine Frage
von Fehlerkultur also wir haben
natürlich alle mit den Anspruch dass wir
so wenig Fehler wie möglich machen und
das sollte auch der Anspruch sein gerade
in der Politik ich habe den auch aber es
wird natürlich nicht immer funktionieren
es werden weiter Menschen Fehler machen
da finde ich es als Minister richtig
dass man sagt beim ersten Mal da gibt es
noch mal ein zweites Chance aber es muss
auch Glas sein es gibt eine dritte
Chance eine vierte Chance eine fünfte
Chance sondern dann muss man der
Gesamtschau sagen dann geht es eben
irgendwann auch nicht mehr und das ist
dann am Ende konsequent das heißt der
erste Fehler den sie der vergangene
Woche haben sie ja den Staatssekretär
noch verteidigt sie auch ich habe damals
schon gesagt und dazu stehe ich auch
heute das waren ganz klarer Fehler was
die Besetzung bei der DNA angeht dieser
Fehler wird auch weiterhin geheilt das
bleibt natürlich auch dabei dass es
jetzt weiter neu ausgeschrieben wird
jetzt aber neue Sachverhalte dazu
gekommen und am Ende muss man natürlich
eine Gesamtschau sich anschauen und da
zu sagen naja sowohl was Vertrauen
angeht also was kommt Lions angeht ist
dann ein Schritt zu weit gegangen worden
aber die politische Fehlerkultur bin ich
finde ich interessant weil eigentlich
ist doch die vorderste Aufgabe wenn man
so einen Schatz im Ministerium hat in
dem Fall einen grünen äh Vizekanzler den
zu schützen am Ende und nicht
Staatssekretär und deswegen finde ich es
ist nicht konsequent sondern es ist
überfällig gewesen und da wurde ein
Reißleine gezogen weil am Ende bleibt
das ein Haarwerk hängen und das kann er
nicht weder im Interesse von Herrn
reichen der ihm ja offenbar nahe steht
sein noch im Interesse von Herrn selbst
noch im Interesse der Kunden ich glaube
es eine Frage wie lange gewartet ist die
Frage sozusagen die sich daran
anschließt ich habe verstanden was die
Frage ist tatsächlich müssen diese
zeitlich Ablauf wann trifft mich welche
Entscheidung ich kann ehrlich gesagt
verstehen dass viele Bürger jetzt denken
warum nicht früher warum ging das
eigentlich nicht schneller aber ich
finde es richtig in so einer Situation
zu sagen man trifft nicht willkürlich
über haftet schnell Entscheidungen wenn
eine Information auf dem Tisch liegt
soll man trete noch mal jeden Stein um
man schaut sich alles sehr sehr
sorgfältig an und am Ende trifft man das
sorgfältige Entscheidung das ist ja
jetzt an der Stelle passiert wie gesagt
jetzt ist die Entscheidung getroffen und
ich glaube es ist auch eine Einladung zu
sagen wir kommen davon weg dass es vor
allem Personaldebatten gibt über
einzelne Personen und kommen wir zur
Sache Politik
vielleicht können Sie das noch mal
beschreiben was ihrer Sicht worin
bestand dieser erste Fehler von dem die
Grünen Spitze und auch der Minister
selbst sagten
dafür muss man keinen Staatssekretär
Opfern das stehen wir gemeinsam durch
was ja menschlich sehr sympathisch ist
menschliches
worin bestand dieser erste Fehler also
es ging einfach nicht darum dass eine
sachliche Entscheidung falsch getroffen
wurde das wäre ja bereits bei der
gasumlage bei Herrn reichen auch der
Fall gewesen hätte man schon sagen
können das ging daneben das hat sachlich
nicht gepasst er hat einfach eine
Personalentscheidung getroffen und hat
irgendwie vergessen das weiß ich eben
nicht und das finde ich auch fehlerhaft
nicht zu sagen Leute ich kenne den total
gut dass mein traumzeuge und ich bin
entweder
raussetzung der Deutschen Energieagentur
hoher Posten herr Schäfer so der Name
des Herrn der jetzt auch seinen Job
bevor ihn überhaupt angetreten hat
wieder verloren hat also der wird sich
auch noch mal überlegen jemand noch mal
die Ehe nicht verspricht oder sozusagen
als Zeuge bereithält aber
das geht nicht ich kann nicht als
führender Mann in einem Ministerium in
einer Firma irgendwo sagen ich schweig
mal still über Verbindung dahin und
deswegen war das glaube ich der größere
Fehler das was Robert Habeck heute
genannt hat war ja so im Zuge der Affäre
Dinge wo man sagen würde also vielleicht
wäre das gar nicht weiter sag jetzt mal
hart aufgefallen ja das würde ich auch
sagen es war am Ende Gesamtschau also es
war jetzt nicht das ist der eine Punkt
nimm uns aufhängt sonst gab diesen sehr
klaren Fehler bei der Dehner der ja auch
von mir so benannt wurde von Patrick
reichen zu benannt wurde und wo
natürlich wenn es da nicht ein mangeln
Fingerspitzengefühl gäbe dann würden wir
jetzt nicht hier stehen wo wir stehen
und sagen ja deshalb wird jetzt auch
diese Entscheidung getroffen dass er
nicht weiter als Staatssekretär arbeiten
kann aber wie gesagt man hat in dem
damaligen Mann gesagt das kann geheilt
werden dass mir auch wichtig das wird
weiterhin passieren also dieses
Ausschreibung Verfahren wird weiter neu
aufgesetzt das ist natürlich komplett
klar aber am Ende wenn man jetzt eine
Gesamtschule natürlich auch ein
Vertrauen geht aber sie argumentieren
immer mit der Gesamtschau ich bin noch
mal gerne auf diesen auf diesen Punkt
hinaus also sie sagen das ist eine
wichtige Agentur die deutsche
Energieagentur die macht was warum ist
die so wichtig für das Land
beschreibt sozusagen wie die
Energiewende fortgesetzt werden soll und
weil da der oberste Posten ein Top
Posten dieser fortgesetzten Regierung
ist sozusagen und mit hohen Gehältern
einhergeht und einfach ganz nah am
Minister auch ist also es ist einfach
ein politischer top Job so das ist ein
politischer top Job und ich interessant
ist wenn man in die Details einsteigt
wie es meistens interessant ist wenn man
die Details einsteigt da wird jetzt also
ein Mann ein Topmann für diesen Top Job
gesucht es wird eine Personalagentur
beauftragt ist das richtig das weiß ich
er sagt nicht ich bin noch nicht in den
genauen Ausschreibungsverfahren mit drin
okay also nach meiner Kenntnis eine
Personalagentur beauftragt
es werden 18 Kandidaten werden sozusagen
gesucht
und es stellt sich hinterher heraus
Patrick reichen der wichtigste Mann von
Robert Habeck hat dieser Personalagentur
die den Job hat diese Kandidaten zu
finden 18 9 Kandidaten vorher schon
aufgeschrieben
darunter sein Trauzeuge Michael Schäfer
ist das denn ist das ein offenes gutes
demokratisches Verfahren ist das klug
das so zu machen nein auf gar keinen
Fall einfach klug wäre wenn es richtig
wäre dann würden wir weder das Verfahren
neu aufsetzen noch würde Patrick reichen
jetzt gehen zum anderen Punkt
er nicht deswegen gegangen ist ja der
Punkt
oder ist ganz klar aber der Faktor das
war ja der Moment wo sie beide gesagt
haben der Mann darf bleiben reicht ihn
nicht
sie sagen es war nicht klug ich würde
sagen es war sehr unklug warum reicht so
ein Fehler nicht um zu sagen das ist
nicht mehr tragbar auch um sich selber
zu schützen und zweitens damit nicht der
Eindruck entsteht es gibt da draußen
ohnehin diese große Erzählung die
stecken alle unter einer Decke die sind
sowieso alle gleich und genau die
Debatte haben das politische Projekt zu
schützen um was es ja ja weg vor allem
geht also vielleicht dazu zwei Sachen
einmal muss man sagen bei manchen Dingen
die sieht auch im gegangen genannt haben
wenn dann vom Plan Strukturen der Rede
ist oder von einem Paten dann ist das
teilweise auch komplett überzogen Kritik
ist an dieser Stelle notwendig aber gibt
natürlich auch komplett überzogen
aber das ist die CSU muss man sagen wo
die politische Makellosigkeit zu Hause
bleiben
aber tatsächlich ist es natürlich am
Ende eine Frage von Vertrauen und ich
würde erstmal sagen wenn es darum geht
wer ernsthaft Vertrauen in Klimaschutz
beschädigt dann sind das die Leute die
gegen Windräder mobil machen das sind es
die Leute die jetzt gerade
Unterschriften gegen Klimaschutz sammeln
aber klar bei dem was wir uns
vorgenommen haben auch als Regierung
dieses Land auf dem Pfad zu
Klimaneutralität zu bringen da bei den
Wirtschaftsstandort zu erhalten das Land
auch durch diese Krisen durch zu
navigieren da ist Vertrauen eine
verdammt wichtige Währung wahrscheinlich
die wichtigste und zwar am Ende zu sagen
ja wenn der Eindruck entsteht diese
Vertrauen ist nicht mehr da dann ist es
auch im Sinne der Sache jetzt ein
Schritt zurückzutreten das heißt ich
glaube am Ende war es auch für das was
wir uns politisch vorgenommen haben
jetzt eine richtige Entscheidung
können sie mir trotzdem noch mal sagen
warum sind da keine keine
Leitplanken eingebaut die so etwas
verhindern warum bei einem Top Beamten
wie wie Herrn reichen warum klingelt da
nicht alle Alarmglocken wenn man sagt da
suchen wir 18 Kandidaten ich schreibe 9
von denen selber auf und einer davon ist
mein Trauzeuge
das klingt man selber vor das müssen Sie
ihn selbst fragen ist
naja am Ende wurde es ja verstanden dass
er wurde es öffentlich gemacht da wurde
es transparent gemacht und da wurde ja
auch diese Fehler aus der Welt geräumt
wenn es da gar kein Bewusstsein gegeben
hätte wäre ja all das nicht passiert
aber wie gesagt das ist an der Stelle
klar ein fingerstation Gefüge fehlt hat
und das ist extrem unklug war das müssen
Sie mir gar nicht entlocken sondern da
bin ich sehr sehr klar naja sie haben ja
gesagt das ist kein Fehler der dazu
reicht dass dann eine Staatssekretär
zurück politischen politischen Maßstäben
hätte er einfach vielleicht auch selber
sagen müssen das war's sorry habe ich
mich so falsch verhalten also Chef zu
schützen ja und mein ja also um seinen
Chef zu schützen denn um den geht's am
Ende an Staatssekretär hat ja äh ist ja
irgendwie Verband oder so sondern das
ist ja der wichtigste warme Ministerium
der aber klar ein Chef hat oder eine
Chefin und das ist immer der Minister
und da habe ich nicht verstanden warum
er nicht von sich aus auch schon gesagt
hat oh riesen Fehler so der Name also
das dass meine Unterschrift mal in einem
großen Stress ich meine so bei so
Staatssekretärin ist jeden Tag Eingang
klar
aber wenn man Namen kennt und weiß und
dann seinem Chef das nicht äußert das
habe ich
gewünscht das herrg reichen von sich aus
früher sagt ich gehe um auch jemanden
wie habe ich nicht in die Verlegenheit
zu bringen sich schützen vorstellen zu
müssen
ich finde es richtig dass jetzt am Ende
diese Entscheidung gemeinsam getroffen
wurde natürlich kann man jetzt viel
lamentieren wann wäre was richtiger
gewesen wann wäre was sinnvoller gewesen
sie frag sie ja aber
bitte ja das ist mir bewusst aber genau
das grünen Chef in scharf jetzt drauf
und halte es echt gar nicht so sinnvoll
jetzt lamentieren nach hinten zu schauen
wann hätte ich mir an welcher Stelle was
gewünscht sondern für mich ist wichtig
was jetzt passiert ist das ist diese
Klarheit gibt und dann jetzt tatsächlich
auch der Blick nach vorne also was kommt
jetzt eigentlich danach diese sehr
langen sehr ausschweifend nach vorne
blicken wollen in eine glorreiche
Zukunft wir müssen trotzdem erstmal
diese Vergangenheit aufarbeiten ein
bisschen tut mir leid ich bin jetzt
heute hier therapeutisch tätig noch mal
die Frage wenn wenn sie doch merken wie
sie auch als Partei unter Druck geraten
wenn sie sich das letzte Wahlergebnis in
Bremen angucken wenn sie merken da
passiert gerade was und da ist unser
großes Projekt Gerät gerade akut in
Gefahr auch deswegen weil es enormes
verhetzungspotential wird
wie konnte ihnen das passieren dass sie
so lange an einem Mann Festhalten von
dem sie wussten das wird jetzt
weitergehen und zwar so lange bis es
nicht mehr geht ja das zu Beginn schon
mal gesagt ich finde dass es auch dazu
gehört in der Politik zweite Chancen zu
geben aber es gehört nicht dazu immer
weitere Chancen zu geben das heißt wenn
wir eine Fehlerkultur reparieren wollen
und ich verstehe wenn sie jetzt sagen
natürlich gibt es das schwerwiegende
Fehler und das war der schwerwiegen zu
dieser Situation ich glaube da lässt gar
niemand ein Zweifel dran aber zu sagen
ja man gibt eine zweite Chance auch
natürlich mit Blick darauf wie wir durch
das letzte Jahr durchgekommen sind aber
dann wenn man merkt jetzt fehlt so viel
Vertrauen auch gesellschaftlich dann
auch die Reichweite dann kann der zweite
Fehler von dem sie sagen eigentlich der
kleinere Fehler ne wenn man so will was
ist da passiert ja da ging es um
eine Ausschreibung für den Bund den
Berliner Landesverband des Bundes und da
stellte sich eben raus dass die
Schwester von Herrn Graichen
Landesvorsitzende war zu dem Zeitpunkt
jetzt ist sie glaube ich noch
Vorstandsmitglied
Verena greifen und genau da wurde eine
Ausschreibung unter ihm vorgelegt und
unterzeichnet und das ist jetzt mit
denen ich weiß gar nicht ob die jetzt
schnell entworfen worden sind die
Compliance Regeln im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium bislang
liegen sie aber noch nicht vor aber
offensichtlich hat man festgestellt dass
das doch ja ein Fall politische
Einflussnahme ist fand das jetzt heute
nicht so schlimm
letzte Woche
interessant war ja heute wir haben ja
Robert Habeck gesehen der ist voll die
Presse getreten es kam zwei Stunden
vorher gab es Gerüchte um 11 hat er das
selber aufgeräumt er hat ganz lange
geredet jedes Wort gefühlt abgelesen von
dem Kommunikationsprofi der ist der da
wirklich auch genau vorgelesen hat er
hat sich am Ende mit einem sarkastischen
Satz wie ich finde der auch zeigt wie
sehr unter Druck steht mit Galgen Humor
verabschiedet er hat nämlich gesagt der
Nachfolger von Herrn Graichen wird nicht
sein Trauzeuge sein das kann man auf
diese Art abräumen aber es zeigt
natürlich auch was wie bitter das ist
und genau aber Frau reichen die wiederum
mit einem anderen Staatssekretär im bmwk
verheiratet ist also es gibt da das
klären alles noch ein bisschen weiter
aber
hören wir einmal kurz rein in genau
diese Pressekonferenz von der sie gerade
sprechen und die sehr Erklärung und man
sieht wie jemand da unter Druck steht
ich habe mich in den letzten Wochen
trotz des schweren Fehlers bei der
Diener Neubesetzung vor Patrick reichen
gestellt menschen machen Fehler jeder
und jede von uns aber um den einen
schweren Fehler zu verteidigen bzw damit
umgehen zu können muss ich sicher sein
dass die Compliance Brandauer die wegen
der Verwandtschaftsverhältnisse gezogen
wurde keine Risse hat
diese Risse hat sie nun
in der Gesamtschau hat sich Patrick
reichen damit zu angreifbar gemacht um
sein Amt noch wirkungsvoll ausüben zu
können
vor diesem Hintergrund sind Patrick
reichen und ich gestern Abend in einem
persönlichen Gespräch darin
übereingekommen dass für die gemeinsame
Arbeit nicht fortsetzen ich beabsichtige
daher den Bundespräsidenten zu bitten
Patrick reichen in den einstweiligen
Ruhestand zu versetzen es ist der eine
Fehler zu viel
der eine Fehler zu viel
also nochmal kurz den Vorgang geklärt
und auch da die Frage wie kann sowas
sein wie kann sowas passieren wie nennen
sie das was da passiert also da kommt
ein Projekt vom Berliner Landesverband
des bund.de
Mitglied im Vorstand so und mit der
Unterschrift des Bruders wird dieses
Projekt als förderungswürdig eingestuft
eins von wie vielen von sechs glaube ich
aber einen Wert von 600.000 Euro
nicht so gering ist genau wie kann so
etwas sein dass ihn erstens so etwas
vorgelegt wird ein Projekt das eine
eigene Schwester zu verantworten hat wo
er doch eigentlich sagen müsste Freunde
tut mir leid das macht ihr jetzt bitte
habe ich nichts mit zu tun und dann wird
das Ding noch unterschrieben
ich glaube erstmal weil es hier gerade
ein bisschen angefangen haben auch über
Familienverhältnisse zu reden und sowas
das ist meine Geschwister haben in
bestimmten Konzernen Themen arbeiten
sich gut kennen ist auch klar dass man
genau für so eine Situation es gibt ja
einmal die allgemeinen Compliance Regeln
für die Bundesregierung die relativ weit
gefasst sind und dann gibt sich jedes
Haus noch mal eigene das hat das
Wirtschaftsministerium getan natürlich
auch mit Blick darauf einmal was in
unsere eigenen Anforderungen selbst aber
natürlich auch das ist dort bestimmte
Verbindung gibt und ich finde das ist ja
dann der Maßstab nicht ein diffuses
Gefühl von kennen die sich oder sowas
sondern gab es dann Verstoß oder gab sie
nicht und wenn jetzt das hat der Robert
habe ich selbst eine Auftrag gegeben
dass noch mal wirklich jede Stein
umgedreht wird alles noch mal überprüft
wird sich alles angeschaut wird wenn
dabei was auftaucht wenn man sagt okay
hier liegt zumindest nein das gegen
diese Compliance Regeln verstoßen wird
dann ist doch die Frage ist ja auch die
Bürger stellen gibt es Konsequenzen in
so einer Situation und das ist ja der
entscheidende Faktor ist erstmal wie
kann sowas passieren
ich habe es ja schon gesagt dass da
offensichtlich das Fingerspitzengefühl
gefehlt hat sonst würden wir jetzt ja
gar nicht über Konsequenzen reden nur
mal die andere Frage das ist ja kein
Vorgang ist ja nicht gestern passiert
mit dieser Unterschrift ist ja schon ein
bisschen 22 22 war das so
das heißt
das ist da nicht bekannt
funktionierender Kontrollmechanismen ist
nicht das weiß man alles nicht man hat
jetzt alles noch mal aufgerollt man hat
sich alles nochmal angeschaut aber klar
wird man sich auch anschauen da wo
Kontrollmechanismen nicht funktioniert
haben wie kann man sie verbessern auch
das hat der Robert Hans rote Listen
geben also so schwer immer die heißen
auch noch gleich naja also Verena
reichen Patrick reichen das ist ja nun
bekannt das ist ne wir sind in einem
Umfeld wo man ja auch über grüne
Sympathisanten und meine das überhaupt
nicht negativ aber in diesem Naturschutz
Natur Umfeld gibt es einfach viele grüne
den Grünen da stehende Persönlichkeiten
und das dann sozusagen sein Team ihn
auch nicht davor schützt also und zu
sagen alles was irgendwie in
Zusammenhang mit der Schwester dem
Bruder wem auch immer steht legen wir
dir gar nicht vor oder kommt überhaupt
nicht in deine Nähe also so müsste man
ja agieren und so müsste man ja schützen
denn dass das irgendwann nicht auf ihn
Herrn reichen sondern auf den Minister
zurückfällt
die größte Angst die man haben kann
genau das ist jetzt passiert wenn man
seit wann war diese Geschichte bekannt
diese Geschichte
letzte Woche Dienstag hat habe ich heute
gesagt letzte Woche Dienstag so wie ich
das weiß das letzte Woche Dienstag
aufgetaucht aber das geben könnte
erstmal aus dem Haus die Rückmeldung
dass da keine Probleme gibt dann hat man
sich das noch mal genauer angeschaut und
ab dem Moment wo das klar war wurde auch
die Entscheidung getroffen aber
interessant
ich mir heute schon während der
Pressekonferenz hat Robert Habeck ja
auch so gesagt dass er interessant ich
bin keine Juristin aber offensichtlich
also wenn es jetzt so hört denkt man
boah das könnte eigentlich sofort
aufgefallen sein okay es ist aber
politisch stimmt
immer weiter nachgegangen aber was ja
hinter alledem steht ist glaube ich ist
auch das was was Kerstin Münstermann im
Grunde formuliert
offenbar gibt es da ja gar keine
Rechtsbewusstsein
ich glaube nicht dass dann heute diese
Entscheidung getroffen worden wäre
es offenbar dieses Unrecht Bewusstsein
nicht aber das würde man doch diese
Unterschrift nicht dahin setzen dann
hätte auch ehrlich
auf eine Liste von 18 gesuchten Personen
neuen selber schon mal drauf schreiben
darunter sein Trauzeugen offenbar ist
man sich so sicher offenbar ist das so
eingeübt auf dem weiß das so normal dass
man sagt was ist denn da eigentlich
dabei sonst würde man Fehler weder
öffentlich machen noch Anzeigen noch
dann ja auch die Konsequenzen daraus
ziehen wenn das alles normal wäre dann
wäre heute niemand aus dem lassen worden
ergreifen selbst wusste von beiden
Vorgängen letzte Woche schon
selbstverständlich
dass er das für seine Schwester
unterschrieben hat und dass er sein
Trauzeugen auf die andere Liste drauf
geschrieben hat und hat trotzdem
offenbar nicht die Veranlassung gesehen
von sich aus zurückzutreten was sagt
Ihnen das das müssen Sie ihn selbst
fragen um ehrlich zu sein haben Sie sich
mit ihm darüber mal ausgetauscht nein
warum nicht
doch ist doch ist doch ihr Vitalis
Interesse Robert Habeck zu schützen
das stimmt das ist auf jeden Fall mein
großes Interesse es ist aber auch klar
für mich ich finde übrigens auch wieder
was politische Klarheiten angeht das
nicht anfängt die Parteivorsitzende sich
da ein interministerielle Arbeitsabläufe
einzumischen und deine Entscheidung
reinzufinden sondern ich glaube auch im
Sinne von na Klarheit von der Sauberkeit
auch das getrennt zu halten ist sinnvoll
es geht auch mit ihnen nach Hause ja und
es geht vor allem also ich glaube es ist
aus meiner Sicht ist das eine gewisse
Macht Arroganz die man dann hat und dann
sagt ja egal also es ist ich
unterschreibe mal es ist ja verdient
einer guten Sache man muss jetzt immer
sagen es gab keine persönliche
Bereicherung oder so keine goldenen
dafür geklaut im Gegensatz zu anderen
Parteien muss man ja auch sagen das ist
jetzt also das hat filzcharakter
Geschmäcker aber er ist es gibt keine
persönliche so wir denken an Masken
Skandale und so weiter
und so weiter geradeaus dem Großbereich
CSU vor Gericht mit mit Maske
ironischerweise und Sonnenbrille Frau
Tandler ja es gibt keine persönliche
Bereicherung trotzdem gibt es ja
irgendwie das nicht beachten nicht nur
von Compliance Regeln sondern auch von
Regeln des politischen der politischen
Klugheit und das politischen Umgangs
miteinander und am Ende ist ja hat Herr
Habeck ja gesagt warum er ein reichen so
festhält weil das der wichtigste Mann
der Energiewende ist der wichtigste Mann
der Deutschland durch diesen Winter
gebracht hat alles fein aber gerade eher
gefährdet jetzt mit
dem heizungsgesetz was sozusagen ja also
kommunikativ an Desaster war von Anfang
an wo sie jetzt ohnehin als Partei
drunter leiden wo die ganze Ampel
drunter leidet wo die Rechten gestärkt
werden und dann kommt das noch oben
drauf und dass man dann nicht sofort
sagt also das politische die Idee meiner
Energiewende ist mir wichtiger deswegen
ich habe mich da Fehlverhalten und ich
finde man muss aber einmal sagen als
wenn man so ein bisschen anschauen wie
geht man eigentlich mit Fehlern um und
ich will gar nicht abschreiben dass er
passiert ist und auch in der
Beschreibung von dem was sie gerade
machen was da an wo man sich ein
bisschen fragt warum wurde sowas nicht
erkannt das will ich gar nicht
abstreiten irgendeiner Form aber ich
finde da hat man hier einmal jetzt
gerade ein Minister der hat gesagt hier
ist ein Fehler ich gebe eine zweite
Chance gleichzeitig prüfe ich noch mal
alles und am Ende treffe ich eine
konsequente Entscheidung und ich will
jetzt gar nicht mit Finger auf andere
zeigen weil ich glaube das macht sie
unsympatschen diese Debatte aber wenn
man das mal vergleicht mit wie viel also
was der andere Sachen an andreas Scheuer
an den ich denke da werden viele nicht
ausgesessen bis irgendwann mal so ein
bisschen Nimmerland Tag bis heute da ist
mir ein so ein Umgang wo man sagt
Sorgfalt Konsequenz am Ende aber auch
entscheiden gut deutlich lieber aber
dass ich die politische Konkurrenz da
drauf stürzt so wie passiert ist
öffentliche Anhörung gab das wurde nicht
gemacht verstehe ich nicht jetzt kann
man die Protokolle nachlesen macht es im
Nachhinein nicht besser also ich weiß
nicht ob da die Fehlerkultur wirklich so
richtig gut war letzte Woche bestimmt
dann würde ich teilen ich weiß nicht
aber reichen von sich ausdrücken müssen
schon letzte Woche
ich finde das ist jetzt für mich
tatsächlich die entscheidende Frage
wahrscheinlich würde man heute sagen das
hätte einiges leichter gemacht für mich
ist der weichtepunkt dass die
Entscheidung jetzt getroffen wurde mit
dem Wissen dass jetzt auf dem Tisch
liegt mit der Gesamtschau und mit dem
Ziel da wo man Angst hat oder eine Sorge
hat da geht für trauen verloren weil das
stimmt ja das was sie gerade auch gesagt
haben die Aufgabe die wir haben ist
riesig das was wir natürlich auch mit
den Bürgerinnen umsetzen wollen ist
riesig dafür braucht es Vertrauen und
dieses Vertrauen muss erarbeitet werden
gut und er arbeitet man sich dieses
Vertrauen Frau lang wenn dann auch
plötzlich das Gefühl entsteht da kann
die politische Konkurrenz kann jetzt mal
Querverbindungen ziehen da werden
Organigramme dann plötzlich vorgetragen
und plötzlich merkt was so warte mal die
kennen sich alle untereinander die sind
teilweise miteinander verheiratet wie
wie schätzen Sie das irgendwie werfen
gleich drauf das ist sehr interessant
das mal zu verstehen oder mal zu sehen
die diese Welt über die widersprechen
aber wie bewerten sie das ist das alles
okay oder ist das etwas von dem sie
sagen wenn ach dann müssen wir angucken
naja ich finde das was bekannt ist das
was angezeigt ist dass das transparent
gemacht wird und wo man sich klare
Regeln gibt wie man damit umgeht das ist
in Ordnung also ich meine wenn ich auf
die freie Wirtschaft schaue dann darf
ich noch nicht mal Leute ausschließen
aus bestimmten Verfahren weil es
familiäres Verhältnisse geben würde das
heißt hier zu sagen das schließt sich
automatisch aus von was das finde ich
falsch aber dann natürlich besondere
Anforderungen daran zu stellen dass es
auch klar manche Organigramm muss ich
aber sagen ich habe jetzt Iris noch
nicht gesehen und bin sehr gespannt
darauf dann tauchen dann ja Dinge auch
wie Förderer auf und irgendwelche
Verbindungen wer hat vor 20 Jahren mehr
mit wem Kaffee getrunken und da ist auch
die Frage sind gerade gesagt dass die
Opposition das auch für sich nutzen ihre
Aufgabe als Opposition das auch in
Ordnung wenn man sich aber heute
hinstellt und hört was das meiste gesagt
wurde von der CDU und CSU dann war das
das ist jetzt das Ende des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes da merke ich da geht's
Null und Transparenz da geht's nur um
Aufklärung da geht's auch nicht um die
Bürger sondern da geht's darum gassenöl
Haltung zu halten an den fossilen
festhalten da werden Verbindungen
aufgemacht die haben damit der Sache
einfach gar nichts mehr zu tun